I don't know if you saw The Italian
Prime Minister elect speech this week
the female and she came out and she used
that word a lot she was talking about
identity she talked about religious
identity gender identity individual
identity and this is one of the things
she said that I pulled out she said
because everything that defines us is
now an enemy for those who would like us
to no longer have an identity and to
Simply Be Perfect consumer slaves that
really spoke to me uh because I'm always
talking about how the goal of the system
at large at all of its different levels
is to remove facts to remove people
identity if you remove someone's
identity you essentially make them weak
confused they don't know where to turn
they can't really build a backbone they
don't they can't how can you build a
life for yourself that's productive if
you can't even Define who you are it's
utterly ridiculous it's not grounded in
fact and I think the goal is to create
isolated weak sickly people so what did
you make of her speech and and one thing
that I thought was hopeful I don't know
how you'll feel about this but it got a
lot of play and there were a lot of
people not only in Italy but in the
United States that heard that and said
yeah this is what I'm talking about this
she called herself a woman she called
herself a Catholic she called herself a
mother and she didn't give a [ __ ] how
anybody received it and people were like
yeah where where is this in this country
your take yeah yeah okay well a couple
of things um I I did see that story I
was made aware of it throughout I want
to say a senator or something like that
for a U.S senator was actually drawing
attention to that on his Twitter feed
and I happened to be following that and
um the guy was talking about like how
come why is it that you know mainstream
Western uh media isn't covering we have
a female prime minister in in Italy and
my you know my my smart ass you know
knee-jerk answers well if gender is just
a social construct then why does it
matter if she's a female or not
why bother right I mean that's really
the answer but um but moreover I think
what her her messaging is uh is it
reflects human tribalism and that's how
the machine is built once again we have
an empirical objective state of humanity
that we simply want to uh erase with um
like convincing everybody that gender
doesn't matter identity doesn't matter
National nationality doesn't matter
religion doesn't matter whatever your
tribal affiliations are uh should not be
as big a deal as uh aligning yourself
with this wokesest uh leftist
progressivist uh idea of gynocentric in
that case too
um ideology and that's essentially what
it is so it's it's abandon all of your
tribalism abandon anything that makes
you a tribally identified and belong to
this consumerist culture that is based
on you know
um on wokes's ideologies but I think
what she the larger the larger scope of
what she was saying think has more to do
with human tribalism and I've I've
actually kind of locked horns with
Jordan Peterson over this as well it's
like I it's my take that a try human
tribalism is a feature and not a bug
that's how we develop societies and
we're all going to lean towards some
form of tribalism so for instance the
company you work for that company is
your tribe the religion you you
subscribe to that is your tribe your
family really is your first try because
there's like you know what's called kin
altruism so your your family your wife
your kids those are your first we always
say family first that's because your
tribe your first your first tribe is
your family you know like For Better or
Worse
um and then there's other like little
sub tribes like if you like for instance
I play in a band that's a tribe when I
go and I and I create music with the
with the people that I create with uh if
you are you know if your your workout
partners that could be your tribe at the
gym human beings form tribes even if
you're like on you know playing World of
Warcraft or something like that you've
got plan or you've got your group that
you go out and you raid with or whatever
it is whatever your you know your game
happens to be human beings will
naturally form tribes but yet we live in
a culture that says no no no you're not
supposed to do that you're only supposed
to follow this narrative and as soon as
you start building tribes and you start
building
um uh you know good tribal affiliations
no matter what it is like I said it
could be it could be ethnicity it could
be religion it could be uh it could be
gender there's there's the the you know
the team woman The Sisterhood Uber Alice
and then there's you know the the
manosphere that could be your tribe and
then there's even sub-tribes from within
the manosphere itself and sub-tribes and
other other areas too so I think it is
foolish to in any way try to form a
society organize Society uh that in such
a way that doesn't acknowledge human
tribalism and doesn't acknowledge the
human machine and the objective
empirical truth of the differences
between men and women first of all but
also just simply between the fact that
humans the reason why we're one of the
reasons anyways why we're the Apex
species on this planet is because of
that were social animals and we form
tribes that's why for better or worse
I'm not saying they're great I'm not
saying they're bad it just depends
that's just the way the machine works
and when you have a social narrative
that denies that or tries to profit off
of like convincing you that that
shouldn't exist that's when you have
problems because people will cling that
much tighter to whatever tribe it is
that they happen to belong to if you
want to watch the full episode you're
going to click right here and if you
want to ask me a question one on one you
want to do a one-on-one face time with a
group of your friends whatever you want
you need to download manect right now
click right here and let's get talking
foreign
[Music]